daryl morey here on the Rich Eisen show
again how are you Darryl morning rich
I'm good you got to enjoy you got to
enjoy these times because sports can get
tough but you know I well I bet and
obviously the beginning of the season
was exactly that but before we wind the
clock back a little bit here but where
were you watching the game are you in
the stands for something like this down
yeah I was I was there for that one that
was I'm still processing what I saw
alive it was it was pretty amazing I
couldn't actually watch that last shot
from Durant I just watched the crowd
react you know you know at that point
you should hopefully win if there's only
a second left but I've lost a lot of a
lot of basketball and you know that's
shot off and go then even with just a
second left so let's put a little bit
more meat on your on your statement last
night best offensive player of all time
James Harden you have the floor Darryl
yeah he's just extremely unique if you
factor in just the overall offensive
package you know if you look at the
volume of often you know the shots that
he takes for a team at an efficient
level I think that's the key so those
two things plus you know others have
done that as well but then you add in
the fact that his passing is that at a
level that's in the top top ten to 20 in
NBA history and the offense that's
produced through that is super efficient
so if you just you look at overall
points produced by a player either to
efficient offense or as passes that lead
to efficient offense and he right there
and I think that the evidence is you
know we were the best offense in the
league last year where I take word yeah
I think we're back to best in the league
this year so a lot of times when other
players who have big offensive
explosions that they're not on the best
offensive league as a team and James has
been leading the top offense since he's
been in the league so he's factor all
that in there really is he's extremely
unique obviously there's been an amazing
players in NBA history but you just look
at it through that lens he's you could
say he's number one
so do
you think daryl morey and you have been
very open over the last couple of years
that you know you have to beat Golden
State you know you have to beat them by
building a team specifically targeted in
that respect last year you were up on
them in a seven-game series
unfortunately Chris Paul couldn't stay
healthy for the rest of it but that
happened last year and now you just went
into their house - Paul - Gordon and
came up with a win do you think you have
reached equivalency with Golden State
Darryl not really I mean I wish I could
say that I would say you know they're
they're the champs they they've been the
best team for four years and not just
the best team you know the best team but
I get margin we do feel like that we are
right there though that were you know I
guess a worthy a worthy challenger where
we've got the pieces to hopefully not
come off but I wish I could say we're
better than a team that should have four
titles in last four years but you got to
prove that on the court well I mean last
night you sure did this doesn't look
obviously I know I'm stating the obvious
like the team that started the season
was there a moment when you saw it all
click yeah we I mean we've we've been
confident all year we look really sort
of people Tyler just naive I guess early
because we did Spence well and people I
think appropriately were questioning
maybe is it all going to work things
like that but we historically we do
struggle early our goals its myself
Coast and Tony chuckles to peak in April
and through the playoffs and we try to
continue to work on the team as you go
throughout the year and you're gonna
struggle you want to struggle early and
sort of bill going forward ad players
add you know either trade or free agency
through the year and I think to many
teams trying to set over try to set
everything up before the season when the
reality is and the NBA's you know I'll
see well you've got to be peaking in
April not you know not in October so
when you see James Harden do you agree
College how red-hot he is or is it just
kind of like Fight Club you don't want
to talk about it I mean what is it what
is the attitude yeah yeah I just I don't
even know what to say you know frankly
when I see him we obviously know each
other well I just I just started I you
just give him sort of a knowing look and
he gives me one back and that I know it
sounds crazy but he's a pretty quiet guy
and you know so there's not not not a
ton of words and you know he knows he's
on a crazy run and but he knows he's got
bigger goals as well so he's enjoying
the ride just like we are and hopefully
we can keep this role going as long as
possible and then get you know Chris
Paul back Gordon back a lot of our key
pieces back and again try and peek in
April to the class when do you expect
them back down yeah Eric to be sooner I
mean he I know there's no exact
timetable from either but I think Eric
will be earlier than Chris but I mean
both had injuries that are gonna keep
them out for extended games daryl morey
Rockets general manager here on the Rich
Eisen show trade deadline just a little
over a month away are you guys looking
to make a move I understand that you're
always going to improve your team etc
et-cetera if you have the opportunity
but is that a goal here for you yeah I
think you know we're we're for now right
whereas when Pete James Harden as people
see and you know Chris Paul obviously
he's still playing in a high level but a
little bit older I mean our our goal is
to it now so yeah for sure we're always
trying to you know trade off some of our
future to help us win now okay and then
are you hoping that harden just blurts
out the names of players that you'd like
to acquire because it would be awesome
and cool to play with as teammates do
yeah I mean there's our superstars I
think this has been a big part of our
success and we recognize them and people
want to say you know great things about
our front office or coaching staff and
as always appreciate it but we're I
think the one thing we know is that this
is really about James Harden Chris Paul
and our
style level players and really it's a
humbling thing that you know they're
both playing on such a high level and
obviously especially James right now
that you know we feel a responsibility
you know to their career and you know so
we're we're constantly focused on how
can we you know help them help them win
so so when LeBron did say - yeah I
missed your question actually so back to
that so there's a constant dialogue yes
with them about potential players you
can maybe come in and help but it's a
it's a partnership with our players and
you know we would we would never bring
someone in that that we didn't think was
a great fit and everyone didn't think
was a great set our chemistry is too
important for that
so when LeBron said publicly you know
duh obviously it would be amazing if if
Anthony Davis came here to the Lakers
are you one of the others in the league
in management in positions like general
manager who thought that that is
technically tampering Darryl well I
can't I mean I can't specifically talk
about what what what he said but you
know I'm not a I personally another
saying of the tampering rules overall
just because they're selectively applied
and you know I'm sort of a free speech
guy so you know we follow the rules as
the league gives us and that's an
important we do that but I personally
don't I just don't like rules that are
applied in one instance and not others
and things like that what do you mean
what do you mean I think it's very hard
to enforce what do you mean by that I
mean I think it was just like you know I
would never be worried about another
team saying some about how they want to
acquire James Harden that wouldn't worry
me at all
if if if if a player because he hears
another player on another team say his
name or another person another team say
his name suddenly goes oh yeah I I've
always been dreaming of living but I
wouldn't leaving this team I hadn't
thought of it till now like it to me
like the rules are don't make a whole
lot of sense so I would just
it's up to the commissioner what he
wants to do but I would I would not have
the tampering room okay so you had no
problem with one superstar just blurting
out the name of another superstar he
would like to play with knowing that
that superstar definitely has sway
within the front office one would think
you don't have a problem with that
I can only comment on our team sir I
would I would not have an issue if
another team or player and another team
said something about James Harden or
Chris Paul it wouldn't bother me at all
I think you know we're putting together
a great situation for them and and if
it's a bad situation you know then
that's one thing but we're very
confident that our top players like
being in Houston
all right daryl morey a couple more
minutes left with the Rockets general
manager heading to Portland are you
there now are you heading there today is
that the scoop right now yeah okay so
you're already there in the beautiful
state of Oregon
so what metric that you place the most
importance on do you think your team is
clicking on all cylinders with right now
that you as a general manager say okay
when I put this team together I'm hoping
to see this result because I know that
that that's what this my philosophy is
or formula might be what are what are
you clicking on the most right now yeah
sure I would say obviously offensive
minute so obvious but yeah we've been
the number one offense by huge margins
for a while now since our slow start and
then more importantly we we feel
confident with James Harden and Chris
that we're going to have an eric and
clink appel we're gonna have a top
offense more importantly as our defense
sort of real slow and we've been taking
that up steadily and we need to we need
to get that in the top 10 for sure and
I'm quite there yet and then last year
we were rolling in the top five which is
well we'll probably need to do if we're
gonna win the title in April and be
armed
all right Daryl are you where are you
gonna watch the the wild card game
between the Texans and the Colts were
you watching that that's a good that's a
very good question I think I think our
trained staff is setting up a watch
party so I think we made it out okay you
and the whole team are you guys all
gonna be together
what does that watch party look like I
think it's like it's not a man it's an
optional thing so yeah probably be a
bunch of the staff well you're not gonna
find harden because he's not watching
the first half of the wild-card time
with you right I think we will rarely
find how nice anything we're trying to
figure out how to give up knowing look
means from him to you Darrell he's
already making the most in the league so
unfortunately there's no way to get him
more but but we for sure you're not
figuring out ways to find him I'll tell
you it really is amazing I'm just a fan
I can't imagine being emotionally
invested because it's a job and you
putting it all together what it must
feel like to watch him on such a roll
right now Darrell it's amazing yeah no
it's I just it's one of those things
here you're gonna be talking to your
grandkids later and saying hey I was
there for that game so yeah it's pretty
special
Darrell thanks for the call let's shut
down the line I know you're gonna be
here in Los Angeles in February we'd
love to have you here in person always
enjoy our child yeah you know let's do
that sounds fun fantastic opportunity
always that's Daryl Morey Rockets
general manager kind enough to call in
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience